okay this latest installment of change
my mind
is regarding the abortion issue i'm
pro-life changed my mind so probably the
most contentious that we've
discussed i would say so can certainly
be argued
warning uh this one is is it 45 minutes
it's like 53.
it's 53 minutes so it's very long and i
know that when you're watching this it
can feel very frustrating i know i did
so i i think it's important to lead with
where this conversation
ends up because that will really help
you understand the context of the
conversation
so when would it be okay i guess to put
limitations let's say on abortion
limitations when is it okay because
we've acknowledged
viability is not consistent but you're
okay with it anyway
you're the only one who's valuing the
rights of of one being
over another being the mother over a
child because you're the one who's
actually proactively terminating life
and you're okay with that i'm simply
saying no one
has the right to terminate another life
just like you don't it's a
non-aggression principle
you don't have the right to hurt me i
don't have the right to hurt you i'm
saying
that person doesn't have the right to
hurt that baby
you're saying it does so you're saying
her rights supersede that of the other
life
living growing inside of her so at what
point
is that okay or not okay i guess is
where it comes down to it it's dangerous
to put
any kind of limitations or controls
around that because she in the end is
the one responsible for that and
and though in those circumstances and i
i don't think that
it's entirely fair to judge them without
being in her shoes i'm i'm not sure
people felt about the decision that i
made but
it doesn't but that again that doesn't
change the essence of what is moral what
is a life it's like saying well listen
i'm against
slavery i think it's bad but if someone
else makes that decision
i have no right to judge their right to
choose slavery because at one point that
was considered okay
it doesn't matter what our opinion is if
that's a life and that's why it's the
only question i would say that really
needs to be answered before we have any
other discussion
so the moment of conception that's where
a woman
loses all ability to make any decisions
no no no you act as though i'm
anti-choice that's not true
well how can you be pro-life and
pro-choice sure i support four choices
contraception abstinence motherhood
adoption okay
the only one have a problem with is the
fifth one that's murder
murder yes so you don't even use the
word abortion you just use the word
murder okay killing what is killing
what's defined what's
what is killing what's the definition of
killing killing
would be the cessation of
the forcible cessation of someone else's
life right murder or killing
let's let's let's let's i'm trying to
see if i can kill the tree but i mean
okay killings will relate to a person
would it be the forcible termination of
someone else's
life killing right okay right now
what is murder it's the cessation of
a formed life it's killing with intent
right to simplify it because otherwise
it's man's thought sure
okay so we agree on murder so if that's
a life
how is abortion not murder because
again at different points it's not it's
not it's
not viable let me answer your question
with as much specificity as i can you
said
yes i believe that once that unique
human dna is created that's separate
from the mother separate from the father
to an entirely new person yeah i don't
support uh the forcible termination so
that's my
view to be just just so i'm very
consistent
so let's look at the fetal development
where is it okay for you what point is
it okay
to kill
so why do i think that's important we
don't do a whole lot of editing with the
change my minds that's what people
really like about it
in this case today we're going to
provide a little bit of commentary again
because it's 53 minutes long it'll be
intermittent it'll be brief
um i think it's important for for you to
see this and for you to note
that some people it doesn't matter how
convincing your arguments are
maybe my arguments aren't that
convincing uh it doesn't matter how
civil you are
sometimes you're not going to get
anywhere and often with you know when
you do q and a's whether it's me at
umass or bench appear answering these
these questions and you see like you
know these montages swatted down leftist
super entertaining yes it's super
entertaining but you don't see those
quiet moments afterward where that
person
sometimes they still think they're right
sometimes their mind isn't changed
sometimes you run into someone in this
case i was wondering my gosh the vi we
go through viability you'll see we go
through the idea of
obviously viability outside of the womb
also the idea of sentience
all this is kind of covered today and i
found myself frustrated
and it is hard to identify sometimes
okay is it me
not doing a good job or is this somebody
who
whose heels are so dug in their mind
won't be changed and i think that when
you see this this woman looked at that
chart
looked at a nine month old baby and said
i don't care no abortion laws
and so i i don't know what to say
to that and you realize there is no
changing there is no common ground
there there's no viability doesn't
matter and looking back on this
conversation if you
think it seems like circular logic and
it's frustrating
it's because it doesn't matter she's
okay with avoiding a nine-month-old baby
anyway
yeah that's why you're never going to
pin her down on any specific issue as
you'll see
that like you like you discussed it
you're never going to find a place
to agree upon because she's that's not
her end game but she brings these up as
smoke screens
nice lady but she means well i think
it's about viability why what about rape
and incest
she doesn't care about any of those
things because she looked at the the
graph
of the fetus zygote feed his baby to use
her words and said
nowhere situational ethics completely
and i think it's important because a lot
of people sometimes will send us emails
and say well how do i have this person
who's coming over to thanksgiving a
family member how do i convince them
sometimes you need to sit in the pocket
you need to take as many swings as you
can you need to try and change their
mind
as best as possible and you need to
accept that it won't happen
anyway and it's hard it's a hard pill to
swallow because
obviously if you're someone who cares
about changing minds you're going to
look back at yourself and say gosh
could i have done a better job sometimes
maybe you can
sometimes it's just somebody who says
abortion up to nine months
no laws at all period so with that being
said that context
uh let's watch this video and kind of
take you through the series of arguments
that brought us to that
conclusion
[Music]
what was your name the way jen jen
stephen nice to meet you
all right general here you can hold this
if you want um just
you know you know talking to the yeah
you're talking to the stick
change my favorite part so i'm just
supposed to tell myself
just talk to me yeah we're just having a
conversation so okay jen
i'm stephen i can hold it if you want me
to yeah that's fine yeah i know
sometimes people get a little
a little more formal i don't i don't
bite so all right i appreciate before we
even set up you were
really quick to say okay is you seem
surprised you said is that for real
when you saw the sign i'm pro-life
changed my mind
why what was so surprising about it um
in my experience dealing with um
pro-life either protests
or discussions normally it's not
change my mind normally it's
they show pictures of actual abortions
or trying to
create women or shame them into
decisions that they've made
it's not really about having um you know
a repartee
it's more about kind of either a
religious ideology
or you know their personal ideology and
just kind of trying to force that on you
rather than
trying to have it understand having a
conversation where we can understand
each other
right and where we're coming from and
why we have these different values
right and also because we're across from
the art museum so i didn't know if
it was a experiment like a social
experiment to see
what people thought you thought it just
might be ironic
i just thought i would ask okay no yeah
it is for real so i am pro-life
okay um and uh you know this is this is
a series we've done it on
gun control we've done it on free speech
uh just listening to the other side
uh giving someone who genuinely believes
from the opposite side of the political
cultural spectrum than i do to
to change my mind to convince me and
have a uh
a respectful but critical dialogue of
issues that you know
we all talk about in today's political
realm but often it's just
it's shouted about right so i am open to
having my mind changed and i have an
international relations degree i've
worked for the united nations i've
worked for the state department so i'm
very much about
understanding and coalition building and
sure discussion
i am not about the shouting okay so um
also my daughter is standing right here
she's a wonderful
shiny example honor student i had her
when i was 16
life is very important to me um
but recently i had a different kind of
um experience so as i promised we'll
keep these commentaries really brief but
one thing you'll notice with changing my
mind anytime someone comes up who's
really hardcore against our viewpoint
they have invariably set up some kind of
a victim status almost always
trans disabled i'm literally autistic in
this case someone who
needed an abortion out of a medical
necessity they use it because when they
feel their argument is is on shaky
ground or their position they revert
back to it you'll see
i am married i also
uh during my experience at the state
department
i was a prisoner of war so i have very
severe ptsd
that causes a seizure disorder and i was
on seizure medication
when i found out that i was pregnant and
i don't know if you know this or not but
when fuses
uh are developing it's actually nerve
bundles
that create you know the arm or the leg
or fingers or whatever sure
and seizure medication by design is
created to limit nerve
bundles and certain synapses and certain
processing
because the person with a seizure
disorder means that they're firing too
much or in a way that they shouldn't be
okay so um found out that i was pregnant
went to uh my ob gyn the same one that
delivered my daughter
and um literally
on the sonogram watch my
baby die cardiac cell by cardiac cell by
cardiac cell
not because of anything a choice that i
didn't make not because i wasn't
just not because i was outside of a
marriage
not because and there was nothing that i
could
do i could either continue to at first
it had
seven cardiac cells and then we went
back to another sonogram and it had four
and then it had three and then it had
two so my options were to
literally let the fetus die and begin
rotting inside of me
or to go to a clinic based on texas law
and get it taken care of before i had to
actually
physically experience jesus
right um so to me um
based on the safety of you know my my
safety and and
if i didn't have a that option available
to me um
and the trauma that that would have
caused i think that there are
unique uh situations especially um
you know when a woman's been you know
raped or whatever
that that that's something that should
be available to them
as a decision that that they make okay
can i ask a couple questions sure of
course
so you first came in i know you said
that you're uh you said life was very
important to you but you didn't say
pro-life
so can we i guess establish what that
means first before i kind of want to
unpack
the personal story which i can only
imagine is harrowing i've never been
through that i'm not going to act as
though i can relate to that
uh i'll do my best as we discuss it but
you said life is very important to you
and then went into that story what does
that mean
i fought for uh life my entire life i've
risked my life for other people's lives
that's why i went into international
relations
i worked at the united nations i was
very successful at setting something up
for people that
live in rural areas setting up social
and economic development for them
it's something that i did in my
dedicated my education to it's something
i dedicated my career to it's something
that i was
eventually captured by rebels in west
africa
you know trying to still fight for right
um
so it's not something that i take
lightly at all
um but the option for
a woman especially given the position
that i was in and and when my
obstetrician that
i'm going to hold this a little closer
because of all the ambulances so forgive
me i don't mean to intrude but
we won't be able to hear you that wealth
but but when i um went to my
obstetrician that i when i was pregnant
with my daughter at 16
or 15 actually i had her when i was 16.
um she didn't
say you know what are you doing go
take care of this so you wouldn't
consider so you asked if we were serious
because
you definitely don't consider yourself
pro-life then in that sense
not in that sense okay um
so my next question is you use the word
you said rather than
endure that trauma right uh did you mean
that for
the baby or yourself
i meant it i guess primarily
watching it every time i went in was
was increasingly more traumatic watching
each cardiac cell
die off sure increasingly more traumatic
do you mean for you or traumatic on the
for me and for my husband
okay right um at that point in time
depending on what you believe the
nervous system hadn't really been fully
formed so i don't know how much trauma
the actual
but it was dying nonetheless and there
was nothing that that we could
have done at that point in time based on
the medication that i was taking
it's interesting to me that you you just
use the word dying
why would you use that word because its
cardiac cells were dying
so without those cardiac cells its heart
stopped and then it sure
but you said it was dying not cardiac
cells it
so that would i guess would we agree
that that is that was a life
that it was a potential life now
important to note here this is not a
debate tactic this is actually very
important when discussing an issue to
find out what
what your terms are to define them so
you're both understanding issues
and um notice how she sort of hops she
jumps
from word lilypad to wordlilypad using
her own definitions absolutely that
happens a lot and now it makes sense
because
she doesn't care where life begins
anyway she uses the word dying she uses
the word cell she talks about heartbeat
and then backtracks
because none of it matters we're okay
with abortions up to nine months let's
keep that context
was a potential life for a life it was a
potential life okay can we can you
help me with this uh again being
pro-life differentiating between the
idea the potential of life
versus a life so when you say that as a
potential life
potential for what a potential
to grow into a
baby that could self-sustain
on some level outside of its mother's
womb so you mean potential human
so the potential human is fulfilled into
actual human
i want to make sure that i'm clear here
so we understand the kind of the terms
we're following
the potential human then becomes a human
when it is sustainable outside of the
womb
i think that that i think that that's
true
i think that that until that point it is
an
a decision between because it
it is completely dependent on on the
mother
sure so to enforce certain
laws or certain acts on her that
the baby wouldn't be able to survive
otherwise
i don't think is exactly
pro-life i mean if you could extricate
the baby
and put it in a you know incubator pod
or something then you know maybe that
would be more ideal
but um forcing a woman who you know in
my situation
was just taking seizure medication you
know because of whatever
and and again not that it matters 100
whether you're married or not but a lot
of people say you know but i was and
yeah it wasn't an economic situation no
no i don't want to get into at all any
of the economic or the moral arguments
or religious arguments i don't think
that does
i think it does a disservice to
everybody we're having this discussion
so i'm just interested in
this concept you said of sustainability
then you mentioned bringing it out and
putting it into an incubator
so the potential for human life we're
now saying
is fulfilled as a human life when it can
survive outside of the womb
then you mentioned an incubator but with
technology for example now you have
babies who can survive earlier than ever
before
so does that change the value of the
life let's say a baby
today who's premature who can survive
three months
four months early outside of the womb
due to technology as opposed to a baby
in the 1940s is today's baby's life more
valuable just because of our technology
i don't think it's more valuable but i
i think it speaks more to
um a woman's rights because a lot of
people that
are pro-life um i i understand that
i grew up with a you know fundamentalist
christian
mother um well i understand that but
let's put that
no one here is a fundamentalist
christian i'm just saying in terms of
you know my viewpoints
and they've been very you know buried in
in terms of you know
my own upbringing but at some point that
child
you know becomes a reality and there's a
mother
that's involved and um
there there seems to be a lot of support
or a lot of fervor around the pro-life
movement and then a lot not a lot of
support about what happens
after that point and putting certain
women
maybe such as the situation i was in or
other
you know situations that are and not
giving them the right to choose what
happens with their own bodies
again trying to keep this brief notice
how she has not answered the question at
all regarding the value of that life
born today versus the 1940s
because i was using her own premise of
an incubator
and now she's on to supporting the baby
after it's born in other words free
stuff free healthcare free college
this is sort of the bumper sticker logic
that we move to and it's important to
bring them into a really
pro life then right if you're really
playing y and z
free stuff um i i try to bring her back
here again assuming that we can find
common ground
now remember she's okay with abortion up
to nine months with no restrictions
period
i didn't know this at the time and what
happened we've just agreed it's not
right it's not your body at that point
if it's a baby in an incubator
right right that's a life right so we
have potential life
maybe in the incubator well that's not
what we're determining right now we're
talking about is i'm pro-life meaning uh
i believe that that's a life
so it's first important i think if we're
going to have a discussion
and determine where we disagree for
example as to where life begins
right okay so according to what you just
said it's not
life it's potential life now then we
talked about technology and
sustainability so
would you support abortions up until the
moment of um
birth how where does where is the line
end then at that point what makes it
okay
versus not okay
when is it a life
that's an interesting question
personally
um and i've never been in the position
of someone who's had to have
one uh
i find partial birth abortions grotesque
you'll see later on though she really
doesn't because she doesn't want to put
any limitations on them
and this is kind of a hedge too
personally but i can't push on someone
else well personally i find murder wrong
but it's not my
it's not my position to tell someone
else if they can or cannot murder
that's why the the definition of where
life begins or whether or not it is a
life at this point she's effectively
conceded that it is
matters so much but some people just
don't care anyway okay
um to me that is a viable life
um that was unnecessarily destroyed and
i think that there's
um parents out there that are willing to
adopt or
or whatever that would be willing to
take over if
the mother is that desperate in that in
that circumstance um
and then my understanding is that that
happens uh
either after six or seven months of the
pregnancy
um typically when when the when the baby
you know
were fully born would be viable
right um so i think that that's kind of
um
maybe uh in terms of when
it's a life when it is
viable outside of the womb
or uh outside of you know
i guess or within um you know
science or an incubator um but
at that point then i think there needs
to
at that point because the discussion of
when life starts is important
but but also then what happens
before i move on like to give you to
give an example right because i'm
pro-life
um so you i understand that you want to
move on afterwards and probably get into
the idea of a social safety net
healthcare i understand where you're
coming from
but before we get there right i'm
pro-life the idea is to change my mind
on this
or or find where we disagree um
before we move on to another discussion
let's say you're driving home tonight
right
and you see someone in the road
ryan you have plenty of assuming you're
not gonna hurt anyone by stopping
pumping the brakes do you stop
if i see someone on the road yeah to not
hit them yes i would too i think we're
probably both decent human beings now
let's say you're the same scenario
you're driving home tonight
you're not entirely sure but you're
pretty sure you see someone on the road
do you stop for the most part yes unless
i
see that person with i don't know like
uh a change so
no no no no i'm just saying if you're
seeing someone crossing the road you
stop you know it's a person and let's
say you weren't sure it's a person but
you saw someone crossing the road and
you could stop would you stop
typically because you'd err on the side
of not ending a life right
and so that's the discussion we're
having here is i haven't heard an answer
on it
perhaps i've missed it where does life
begin because if
if we don't know entirely of course i
would say we both agree have to air on
the side of
of uh allowing yeah of of allowing
the possibility that's a life so where
does life begin i think as far
it's the most important question we
can't move on from that conversation to
uh what happens after birth if we don't
agree where life begins
i don't know if that's entirely true
because
that's also very important it's
important but not if we're
if we're killing a life that's more
important than providing it let's say
with free health care
if we're killing a life right so we have
to get to that point
where does life begin what constitutes a
life
okay and then also what constitutes i've
i've answered a lot of questions so and
and i appreciate your empathy
regarding my situation and admitting
that you've not been in that
circumstance before
what given my circumstance
do you think would have been a better
decision well
again all of these questions are
answered if you can answer the first
question
which is the most important question for
you to determine your position
what determines a life where does life
begin
i have answered it when it's viable
outside the world when it's viable
outside the womb
um but i i don't think that you have
answered it that way so we say for
example that a baby born in
new york city because of the
technological advancements they have to
make it viable outside the womb is
that's a life and that exact same baby
at that same gestation period
is not a life in west virginia where it
wouldn't be able to be viable outside
the womb
what determines viability what do we
mean by viability maybe i'm getting
confused there ability to live
outside of the womb with either
with the assistance that's available or
because it's
matured to that point within its
mother's mood
one thing you notice she uses a lot of
words like personally primarily
notably most likely to hedge her bets
and
she tries to go to the personal scenario
that's why it's so important she set up
me personal victim
so that she can go back to it when she
hasn't answered the question and if this
is where we get to the point where it
seems like circular logic she claims
that she's answered with viability but
she didn't
really answer the question of it does a
point in time 1940s versus today does
geographical location determine the
value of life
she hasn't answered it the reason it's
starting to get circular this is why i
wanted to show the the ending first is
because she doesn't care anyway
she's just trying to she she's just
completely unwilling to concede ground
and this is i should have recognized
this here and probably just jumped to
the fetal chart
but being a dumbass i thought i could
maybe have a civil conversation and
convince her but i didn't realize like
i thought maybe there's a middle ground
i didn't realize her middle ground was
eight months
okay but you mentioned an incubator
right so let's say there's no incubator
within access
matrix style like okay science fiction
not science fiction i mean i don't think
we're too far away from it i'm just
saying that no we're not it's still it
exists right now i mean
more babies are viable than ever before
exactly um
and again but the viability would be
determined by geographical location so
does
does that determine the value of human
life i think it does actually and it has
proven geopolitically that it has
determined life for
so you would agree with that you would
say a life for example and the west
indies is worth less than a north
american life in
lenox hill hospital i think that's the
reality of the situation
so right there in order to avoid the
question she sort of presents this
cynical
viewpoint well i think we've seen that
meaning the human rights issues that
occur in third world countries
but then tries to to sort of shift away
from i said so do you believe that
because the question
was again where do you believe life
begins and you say well we've seen that
society and the technology determines it
and then tries to whole play the whole
the unfortunately
angle but she's the one who presented it
i don't necessarily agree with it or
think that it's optimal but i think that
that
is the reality that we have to deal with
and i think that the reality that i had
to deal with was
not optimal either and that was
not given very many other options except
for literally sit here and watch it
progressively die there's that word die
again until it's
last heartbeat or you know try to
whose heartbeat the fetus's heartbeat
um the the other life's heartbeat
the fetus's heartbeat at
six weeks that was not viable that had
gone from
seven cardiac cells to two right right
but you were talking about how traumatic
it was that it would have been dramatic
to
continue to just go to the obstetrician
and watch it
die further instead of taking die
so this comes back to the issue my issue
is i'm pro-life changed my mind
if if entertain this thought for a while
because we talk about viability right
well viability is sustainability there's
a certain level of dependence obviously
in all stages of development
and certainly after the birth i mean
most babies would not make it
more than half a day after the birth if
not for someone else taking care of that
baby right
so we have to determine what viability
is what dependency is
older people there are some older people
who are entirely dependent who are
entirely non-viable without assistance
i still say that they're a human life we
have people who are in comas who are not
viable without people taking care of
them
i still say that's a valuable human life
when you get outside of
the scientific realm of life and you've
kind of used this term
yourself and you talk about another
heartbeat dying ending that life
after conception right there's a unique
genetic code
that determines male pattern baldness to
eye color to sex
to the heartbeat which is separate from
yours immediately
it's the only consistent line to draw
to determine what life is outside of
that it's circumstantial
and that's where you end up as in your
boat you know valuing certain lives over
other lives i guess you could say that
but it's kind of like
saying well um you know for
and then this is over simplification
obviously when we're discussing humans
but you know like um uh
you know a chick uh hatching you know
purely what's the responsibility there a
tadpole you know leaving its
little egg where it's got its you know
nutrition
and then you know not being viable there
it's it's
it's it's not um
though while they are two separate
questions they
are completely distinguishable in terms
of
what the end result is and so we can
talk about
when life starts but there
has to be a discussion about viability
and and healthcare
and women's rights intermixed in that i
i don't know i mean what do you think
for example a woman that
that that that conceives a child as
the as a product great i mean what
what do you think honestly her her
option should be
what what i think wouldn't change
whether that's a life
or not right knowledge nor ignorance
changes the very nature of something
so it still comes to the question
whether that's a life or not
what i think about rape is that rape is
terrible
that doesn't change the circumstance
that there's a life growing inside of
that woman
okay so that woman's life somehow
is superseded by
no no no not at all
but when being forced to carry that
child
would no i would never force anyone to
carry a child
so then what are the other options
no i'm not forcing anybody to carry a
child um
i'm simply barring someone from killing
a wife but you can't
have it both ways there's no having both
ways i'm not forcing the rapist
has has committed an evil evil act right
and so i'm simply saying that you can't
meet an evil act with an even greater
evil which is the termination of a life
i'm not forcing anyone to bear a child i
would never do that but how do you
say that then conception is where life
starts but you're not gonna
but you would never agree with forcing
someone to carry a child if a woman that
i'm not conceived as a con as the
consequence of a rape
that's why she was carrying a child you
would say you would never
force that on anything no of course not
that would be the rea that would be her
reality
that there would be a life according to
you growing inside of her
that had started and and then what
for example right now if you were to say
i forced you to give this interview
no is that no but let's say you said it
okay would that be true
no so because you say something or
because you think something doesn't
change the nature of it correct
so because you say i'm forcing a woman
by not allowing her to terminate a life
doesn't change the fact that i'm not
forcing anyone to carry a life
by not getting there was a crime
occurred and then i just don't believe
in meeting evil with an even
more evil act i understand what you're
saying but by not giving her the option
you are
well not giving her the option again of
killing a life of murder is what you're
discussing
it doesn't change the nature by not
giving her the option then you are
forcing her to carry a rape child no i'm
not
and whether they're option does she have
other than this carry it would be like
saying you're being
forced for example to take care of your
child
because the law says that you have to
feed that child even though it's
completely
non-viable without your intervention you
entered into a social contract when you
decided to have sexual intercourse with
somebody
willingly and you understand one of the
consequences of that
might be procreation see here she
doesn't see the irony and exactly what
she says the consequences might be
procreation
now we've gotten to the rape discussion
which does again it doesn't matter
because it's okay with an abortion to
nine
months so this was more of a
philosophical point i tried to explain
that simply ignorance doesn't change the
nature of an action
missed so a big swing and a mess so i
thought okay
let's try and bring it back to the vast
bulk of abortions but again
why is she bringing up rape why is she
bringing up the idea of partial abortion
none of it matters that's why i thought
people need to see the conclusion first
you'll see let's let's get back to
uh nearly all abortions which of course
aren't from from rape no that's not why
well that's we're talking about the
nature of what life is right this is the
the deep root
which seems that you continually have
avoided avoiding it i'm saying that
there are consequences beyond that but
without examining it
it's okay but let's let's agree on that
let's say we give you that
let's say we give you that okay let's
say we give you that let's say rape
incest right the
less than point five percent of
abortions let's say we give you this
okay
so then let's get that off the table
give it to you
um what about the vast majority of
abortions which we both know are
committed
because of convenience would we both
find common ground there that that's
immoral
that that's terminating a life and
that's immoral
i would say that based on my experience
in life and based on
things that i've been exposed to that i
think
there should be i think people should be
held to a higher level of responsibility
for their actions
okay and that i do think life is sacred
but for anyone to
go out and judge and say
that this person got into the situation
because of
um convenience or irresponsibility
is an over simplification of most of
those circumstances
and yes i do think that there should be
like i said
increased responsibility and and more
education
but i don't think that that should take
away
the right that the woman has to know in
her own situation
in her own abilities what what she's
which is capable of of doing and capable
of caring for
and capable and the life that will
then exist beyond those nine months for
the rest of its life
i don't think that that i'm not i'm
sorry i'm trying to see what your your
answer was
it was i don't do i think that it's
immoral
that's that was your question yes to end
a life to end a life when it's let's get
rid of rape and incest off the table so
i'm trying to find some common ground
here because we both know statistically
the vast majority of abortions are not
committed for that reason
um so if we take the giant bulk
statistically almost all of abortions
that are currently being committed in
this country
based on convenience or inconvenience
can we find common ground and say okay
terminating a life
which i think we both agreed upon is
immoral
terminating a life in terms of
like abortion abortion
immoral to kill to kill another life
to kill something to kill a person
to kill a person i'm trying to be as
very clear in my terms as possible i
know
because you've been somewhat vague i
want to make sure that i'm not
misrepresenting what you're saying
yes to kill another human being
is immoral to kill another human being
is immoral okay i want that i agree with
that
but i think that
again you need to be careful about the
definition of
of when that starts and
that because there are so many
extenuating circumstances
having actual
laws
or litigation in this country where
i would have had to seek some sort of
i don't know like waiver or something
from my doctor given my personal
circumstances
is also a myth here's something i found
really fascinating right here she admits
that killing a life killing another
human is immoral
but then she says we have to be careful
about how we define
define that life because of
circumstances
when have when circumstances ever
determine science yeah i know and that's
why i should have realized at this point
because
all of her arguments rest in the
circumstantial which which cannot be
proven or questioned and and you see
that as we
it progressively uh it gets
less pleasant it seems that when people
it seems a very common threat when we
have these conversations someone comes
in and says
i am this therefore it's different for
me what i'm trying to do is get on the
table here the vast
majority of abortions and determine when
life begins
there are no true circumstances that are
there absolutely are there absolutely
are yours is a very extreme
case you're you're yours is a very
extreme case actually i had a very close
friend that had the same thing happened
to her but accepted that
statistically it is statistically it is
statistics and these facts matter and
especially when you determine when life
begins
those laws existed then she and i would
both be in very different votes but what
if that saves
billions of lives what if that saves
hundreds and hundreds of millions of
lives again if we need if we need to
have a conversation as to where life
begins
and if we agree on that if we don't
agree on that then that determines
whether you know killing this life
or potential life as someone sees it is
morally acceptable or not
because maybe it's if in some
extenuating circumstances we would say
okay
in this instance this is moral for me
but what about the hundreds of millions
of lives that have been killed and ended
can i ask you a question
here's a point where she hasn't answered
any of my very framed in clearly defined
questions
and so she asks me if this is
religiously based now let me ask you
have you
heard me make any religious argument
here none no so
it your honor i object but this is what
happens
is your belief system uh primarily uh
spiritually based religious based
nothing that i've discussed here has
anything to do with that
purely i i don't think that's relevant i
think what's relevant is determining
where life begins
because you haven't answered i actually
have answered several times you've said
viability but it's been
remarkably inconsistent so yeah it has
no i've said outside of the womb or
outside of scientific
so the value of life differs from say
west virginia
or south africa than the united states
and you support that you're saying
that's okay
i'm not saying that's okay i'm saying
that's the reality and i'm saying taking
the choice away from women that are in
those situations would be a crime
against
their lives oh gosh you know i hate to
commit this is the exact same argument
she made earlier well unfortunately this
is the case this is the reality right we
see that some
babies are valued more than others as
though it's this grave injustice yet
then she says we must continue
to perpetrate this injustice to ensure
that it
it this is where if it seems frustrating
watching but believe me i thought
am i missing this right so you're not at
all concerned with the lives in those
cases
that you're terminating that you're
killing i'm concerned with them
but not much there is a life already
that it is in existence
that is in development that would be
adversely affected so i want to be very
clear here you just said that's the way
it is so you support the premise
that a life is more valuable in lennox
hill hospital
no no you're taking it than it is you
said that's the way it is expensive
because i
as i told you i have an international
relations degree and
i've worked union nations and i've
worked for the students great so i
fought for human rights in people's
lives my
entire career my entire education so
you're reducing what i'm saying a little
bit i'm saying that that is just the
reality
right the world and you use that to
define where life begins correct you
said viability that's
your okay so the value of human life
differentiates based on geographical
location according to your premise
that's okay
my premise the premise that was created
by colonial bowers imperialists whoever
you want to say
but that's why there's differences in
terms of
medical developments and and all those
things in different parts of the world
and i've been
all over the world so i know how life is
valued in different places and that is
sure reality in some places it's okay to
take a sex slave we would both agree
that that's
completely morally reprehensible right i
would agree with that
right so would we not both agree that
geographical location
being born in lenox hill hospital
shouldn't make your life more valuable
than someone who's born let's say in the
plains of zimbabwe who doesn't have an
incubator completely agree with you but
i also agree that the reality of the
situation is that there's always been a
difference in terms of prices on human
life
our country has a really great history
and you support that
then absolutely not okay then it comes
back to where does life begin
but where does life begin then because
you just said that's the reality if you
fight for human rights
what about that basic human right again
the right to life
the right of that child the right of
that baby to be just as valuable
in sudan as it is in in in manhattan
what rights has it
has it been able to wha what what
right as a as a fetus as a baby
fetus as a baby
depending on where it's born it can be a
baby a viable baby or it can be
aborted yeah depending or it can be
something that's just a
death but that's entirely dependent on
where it's born
right but that's the reality of the
circumstance you see that long
uncomfortable pause there the left is so
used to using this
this umbrella fetus umbrella term as
though it just makes it go away
she's used the word repeatedly dying
cardiac cells ending
death but it's all okay if you just say
it's not
i say it's not a baby it's a fetus at
this point even though we're discussing
a viable baby depending on where it's
born
but say fetus and all that goes away
taking that
away from a woman who's in those more
difficult places
who doesn't have those medical organs do
you understand how it's an inconsistent
my point is your viability line is very
inconsistent
it's not a consistent measurement do you
you're ending a human life
with its own dna inconsistent i've
always
maintained viability and i maintain that
there just
are geopolitical differences in terms of
scientific
advancements and in terms of
availability and that's just the reality
and whether if pro-lifers are going to
go around the world
and donate billions and billions and
trillions of dollars and they do
they do far more than u.n they do far
more trail work than the u.n
uh-huh okay yeah statistically you know
this if you fought for human rights a
different conversation
but um i'm just saying that that that's
always that's been a
sad reality and perhaps with more
support and perhaps
with more education that that wouldn't
be the case
and that i do think that um that
no support education i don't i don't
understand
okay let's remove different countries
because maybe that's sort of the barrier
here let's just go to state borders
let's say a baby right now
uh six months old okay six months old
lennox hill hospital
completely viable right best medical
technology available
same exact baby okay hills of tennessee
born the same time one lives
one dozen all right so does that make it
acceptable uh or one life less valuable
to abort at that term in pregnancy
where is it okay when is it okay to
abort because we've now determined that
viability
can vary right so is
at that point we would say abortion's
not acceptable because it could be
viable outside the women
the point we were making was you
mentioned viability you mentioned about
you said viability
you were talking about when does life
begin yes i'm wrong you said viability
so that is determined by where they
could be born or when they could be born
right there are a lot of different
circumstances so to those different
circumstances
determine the actual value the essence
of human life
is that your presupposition if you want
to talk about the value of human life in
terms of like an overarching definition
no so here we go this is where i should
have just brought out the fetal charge
he says if you want to talk about the
overall idea
of the value of life no but the reality
yes in other words she's saying
that yes value is determined by
technology
by your access to doctors to your health
care provider
that determines whether you are a human
or not
and um that's why the conclusion was was
so important because now you see why
this this just non-stop circular logic
makes sense from her position if you
want to talk about the reality then yes
okay so the reality is even though that
baby is viable as you've
just agreed you'd be okay with aborting
it if it's in a place where
it wouldn't be able to be put on support
i said that i believe that life begins
at viability
i and i said that unfortunately
and based on experience whether you want
to not if you want to take other
countries out of it then that's fine
even though that's the
majority of the world's population then
i didn't because you said geopolitically
so go ahead and take put it back in put
it back in
put it back in for your argument put it
back in no no it's fine put it right
back in there i don't need to
um i'm just saying that viability is
is one thing life is another
and yes uh lives have always had
different values
viability is one thing life is another
but you just said that viability is what
determines
a life i said
that in terms of you said it would
abortion be okay where there weren't the
scientific avail
advancements available in one place
versus the other
and i didn't i was asking the va is the
value of the life
determined by that technology or by the
era in which
the baby is born unfortunately yes okay
so to you that's what determines the
value of you
not to me to the rest i'm asking you
what is your opinion then
convince me because my my opinions
there's no consistent line i'm trying to
be as clear in terms as possible
there's a unique human genetic code
created at conception you mentioned the
heartbeat that's not your heartbeat it's
not the father's heartbeat
right you don't have when you were uh
giving uh when you were carrying your
your lovely daughter there you didn't
have four feet
you didn't have four hands you had a
separate
life living inside of you my
contention is of course that
scientifically that life we see begins
at conception
dna is created you said viability
and then i was just showcasing how
viability is determined by geography by
different points in history
and then you said i don't support it but
that's the way it is so i'm asking you
where is your line as to where life
began
again my life is that viability
and this is like you were talking about
before this is where that kind of cross
section occurs
uh where we're far far far right and far
far left to meet
where culture determines yeah your value
and morality
it comes from your immediate culture
right not science there is no
intrinsic value um it is remarkable but
again
when you don't care if it's a
nine-month-old baby all of this
makes sense if that isn't your position
almost none of this makes sense it's
certainly absolutely inconsistent
yeah all of smoke screen do i support
the differences in different places
where viability begins no but until
we have more equality as far as that is
concerned
i don't believe in taking the right away
from women
to make certain decisions so you've just
acknowledged just want to be clear
that a viable life
because of its geographic location you
are okay with killing i'm not okay
i'm saying that's the reality of the
situation so you are against it
but it's a reality situation i'm saying
that i wish that that
mother could get more support and
education
but but that wouldn't change viability
at that point there's a life growing
inside of you this this baby is six
months let's say five months let's say
seven months
if the mom could have a phd it doesn't
change the fact
that if that baby's born premature it
won't survive in this area of west
virginia compared to manhattan it
doesn't change anything
but you're okay with aborting let's say
at that point
notice there's no response the left is
so used to going completely
unquestioned where their solution for
everything is
more education more health care more
support
more funding translation
even though it doesn't change anything
and in a sense that's why she doesn't
respond to it because it's
it's the first time i think this kind of
a premise has gone questioned with her
it
i think it's situational what i'm not
okay with is taking away
a woman's right to make certain
decisions
about her body and i think that that but
that's not her body right we've both
established that
but it is though but it's not it's not
if it lives in new york and it doesn't
live in west virginia you're just saying
again you're saying
well okay here i'm against it because it
can live
in a hospital in the upper east side but
here i'm not i'm saying that
that's not her body it is that those
differences
exist scientific advancements
those differences exist i completely
agree support all of that
those things exist and until we get
some more even ground on that i think
but does that change the essence of
personhood
does science change the value of life
does science change the essence of what
a human being
is i think it's proven that it that it
has i mean we could go
way off talk and talk about human
workform
or steroids or science yes it doesn't
that doesn't determine a life
yes it does it changes the essence of
the life it changes the quality of that
what is
personhood what makes a human being a
human being i guess is a question what
makes a human being
what determines a human life and and
that's just i feel like we're getting
hung up there because i'm just not
seeing a very consistent rationale
and applying your standard here and it
seems like we're going in circles if it
seems inconsistent
it's because i think it's a dangerous
segue into removing
rights that shouldn't be removed because
there are unique situations and because
there are these differences and because
there are a lack of resources
and because there is a lack of education
and
saying that well
this is where life begins then you're
automatically getting into discussion
about
murder and i don't think that that's
appropriate why isn't that appropriate
if it's a if life has begun
and you're ending that life again it's
about viability and we have just had a
discussion about how
that's different in different places and
how life is valued differently and
different
right but in in my point is that with my
position
uh killing that life is very consistent
it doesn't matter whether it's two
months or three months or six months it
doesn't matter what i would
live in new york and not in the sudan it
doesn't matter whether it would live in
west virginia and not in the hospital in
tennessee none of that matters in my
instance because
i'm concerned with the rights of that
life and we both agree that in some
instances
that life may be viable it may not be
viable over the rights
of the person carrying it no not over
the rights of the person carrying it i'm
simply not allowing i'm simply not
allowing
the killing of one life not allowing the
killing of one life is not forcing
one that you've acknowledged is viable
is not
forcing somebody to do anything yes it
is
what's important here is we're both
discussing a life at this point that
we've both agreed is viable outside of
the womb she wants to go back and forth
based on convenience for her that's why
this is so um
disturbing we both agree that we're
discussing a life viable outside the
womb
and she still doesn't care and this is
where it snowballs pretty quickly
forcing someone to carry a baby
to whatever term especially
in extenuating circumstances or where
the lack of resources that that is not
realistically viable i think it's
outside of the world
so i think i i think that you know i i
um so when would it be okay i guess to
put limitations let's say on abortion
limitations when is it okay because
we've acknowledged
viability is not consistent um but
you're okay with it anyway
you're the only one who's valuing the
rights of of one being over another
being the mother over a child
because you're the one who's actually
proactively terminating life and you're
okay with that
i'm simply saying no one has the right
to terminate another life just like you
don't it's a non-aggression principle
you don't have the right to hurt me i
don't have the right to hurt you i'm
saying
that person doesn't have the right to
hurt that baby
you're saying it does so you're saying
her rights supersede that of
the other life living growing inside of
her so
at what point is that okay or not okay i
guess is where it comes down to
what point is it okay to violate the
non-aggression principle and terminate
another life
um again i uh had made my statement
pretty clear
on partial birth abortions i personally
find them
abhorrent i know one particular
situation that was
you know whatever but um you know maybe
an argument can be made but still um
but um
i i think that that's where
the um education
needs to come in i think that um
and and i i think you're maybe
diminishing a little bit
the fact that it's not an easy decision
for the mother it's it's not it's not
optimal it's not it's not something that
that any woman actually that i've ever
spoken to
wants to do um
i don't
again i think because of the amazing
amount of circumstances that a woman can
experience and endure that it's
dangerous to put
any kind of limitations or controls
around that because she in the end is
the one responsible for that
and and though in those circumstances
and i i don't think that
it's entirely fair to judge them without
being in her shoes i'm i'm not sure
people felt about the decision that i
made but
it doesn't but that doesn't change the
essence of what is moral what is a life
it's like saying well listen i'm against
slavery i think it's bad
but if someone else makes that decision
i have no right to
judge their right to choose slavery
because at one point that was considered
okay
right that doesn't someone's opinion on
an issue doesn't change what it is it
doesn't matter what our opinion is on
gravity
doesn't matter what our opinion is on
slavery if it's immoral
indentured servitude that's immoral it
doesn't matter what our opinion is if
that's a life
and that's why it's the only question i
would say that really needs to be
answered before we have any other
discussion
so at two weeks three weeks
not even you know observable other than
under
a microscope at the moment of conception
that's where a woman
loses all ability to make any decisions
no no no you act as though i'm
anti-choice that's not true
well how can you be pro-life and
pro-choice sure i
support four choices contraception
abstinence motherhood adoption
okay the only one have a problem with is
the fifth one that's murder
murder yeah so you don't even use the
word abortion you just use the word
what is killing what's defined what's
what is killing what's the definition of
killing
killing would be the cessation of
the forcible cessation of someone else's
life right murder or killing
let's let's let's i'm trying to see i
can kill the tree but i mean
okay killings will relate to a person
would it be the forcible termination of
someone else's
life killing right okay right now
what is murder um
murder would be an aggressive
uh typically pre-meditated
act um to
it's the cessation of a formed life
it's killing with intent right to
simplify it because otherwise it's man's
thought
sure okay so we agree on murder so if
that's a life
how is abortion not murder because
again at different points it's not it's
not it's
not viable it's a consistent pattern
that we see
throughout nature when things aren't
valuable when a mother doesn't have
proper resources
that that she takes care of it
because of knowing what the experience
will be of that child
and of her family and her ability to
ever starve to death on a you know
ice flow or whatever i mean it's it's
it's a pretty
consistent um let me answer your
question with as much specificity as i
can you said
yes i believe that once that unique
human dna is created that's separate
from the mother separate from the father
to an entirely new person yeah i don't
support
the forcible termination so that's my
view to be
just just so i'm very consistent so
let's look at the fetal development
where is it okay for you what point is
it okay to kill
that's an interesting question because
you're using the word kill
and murder let's remove murder and kill
let's assume that
the abortion is accidental so it's not
murder again i
don't believe in putting these at what
point is it i've said
unique dna it's separate from the mother
and father at that point the only
consistent line
of course in comparison to viability
sustainability
here you sound like question mark you're
not sure i don't know with this
ovulation period so i'm trying to see
where the actual conception is taken
care of before
i mean is taking place according to what
you put in front of me yes okay so
that's conception week one
okay so where is it okay to
where on this chart are is it morally
okay to kill
okay morally okay to kill again is a
difficult uh
question and it's putting me into a box
okay where is it morally okay to
terminate a pregnancy let's use that
term
i'm just trying because i've answered
the question i hope as clearly as i can
conception
so i just would like to see it pick on
the scale maybe that'll determine where
we disagree
it's not i mean because i'm looking at
pictures of developing babies and i can
see their characteristics forming in
their fingers and their toes and i
understand what's going on and
i had a very uh difficult pregnancy with
my daughter so i went into the doctor
two or three times a week so i know
exactly where is it okay
again i think it's very dangerous to put
these very specific lines and say
okay for this woman x this is the point
for this woman why
this is the point i don't i don't agree
with putting those distinctions
because we don't know where is it okay
we don't know if she's in virginia to
end this life she's in new york
we don't know if she's been raped we
don't know what the circumstances are
being a person that
suffered uh has ptsd myself you know the
trauma of a rape or whenever
she's able to actually take care of it
that's a separate question
that's that that's irrelevant where is
it okay to kill that light irrelevant
i'm saying it's dangerous to put those
parameters on but they already
they do exist they do exist the
parameters exist whether you like them
or not i like them
there's exist but there are laws there
are exactly there are legal avenues
there are laws
so i'm asking your opinion where should
the law be
where is it okay i don't think there
should be one
i think that there are unique situations
i don't think that we should
i don't think that we should be
mandating women's rights that way so no
so nowhere here should there be any law
no i don't think there should be a law
there shouldn't be any law that you
can't recently so i feel about it
morally
does not change not just
does not change what her personal
experience is and
it doesn't change what this is it
doesn't change what these things are
you're looking right now
you're supposing that and i have a real
woman standing in front of me telling
what's really going on but this is real
this happened millions
many many millions i mean you're talking
about each week
that's real so why is it at what point
is it okay
you asked me i said conception this is
where dna is created
it's entirely different you talked about
you know heartbeat obviously unique from
the mother and father i've given you a
clear answer and i've given you
clearance
you haven't you said you you know so you
don't believe in any limitations at all
i think that
there are situations that are so unique
that to put laws on them
would be to be a travesty and would be a
punishment for certain women
okay well
the fact that you're okay terminating
this i told you already it doesn't
change my mind
partial birth abortion to be well then
just pick the chart point tell me where
tell me where partial birth abortion
tell me where it's okay
i told you pick a baby and point and
that's an answer personally
find it extremely repugnant and
distasteful but i know of a specific
circumstance
where you know i i can't be the judge of
that and i think that
it's again dangerous to start this
this discourse without having other
things like the education and blending
in place
because when you start how is this
education right here this tells you
exactly what kind of development
where the baby is at each week is that
on education right now you have the
education of what that fetus
zygote fetus baby to use your terms is
couldn't possibly be more informative
until we have more education
that's honest in this country about how
uh contraception works be a more
responsible
mentoring programs in terms of
relationships and and how
um you know conception works
until there's a support network that's
in place
for these women that would have made
other decisions but as you say you
support um
adoption and then that's a clearer less
you know guilted morally repugnant
pathway woman has to hang her head for
nine months and then painfully give away
until those things have changed i think
it's dangerous to set these precedents
and make these laws because
we don't have the support mechanisms in
place for the after effect
sure okay so no abortion laws
appreciate that's your opinion very
honest about it thank you hasn't changed
my mind but i appreciate you taking the
time
oh okay so that was uh that was pretty
tiring that was pretty exhausting i
find it at the end she's just bringing
up my points whether it's
whether it's it doesn't take into
account whether it's new york or
virginia that's the whole point that's
the cold key
that's what i was saying you know how
you do this because when you
when we take these i'm far enough away i
don't hear that what's going on
you just had to live through this twice
why because you know that when you said
stupid things i've tried to ring your
neck
exactly it goes against my nature it is
really and i think it goes against a lot
of of human nature
um and that's why it's sometimes in the
moment humiliating where you're going
gosh i'm really not a good
i'm not able to convince it but then you
realize at the end it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter
i don't know what you say if you were to
say to someone man the holocaust was
really true
we shouldn't let that happen again and
someone says yes but some of the jews
were stealing money
so she was like well uh i don't i don't
know you're so you're okay with it
i well don't know fl oh by the way her
daughter
it turns this is yeah her daughter's
people were taking some pic her daughter
was a fan her daughter's boyfriend in
the military was a fan
so hi gia um
listen your daughter was very nice this
is not this whole thing is
is designed to be the opposite of just
cable news sound bites yeah
fighting arguing not being productive
but um
the the back flips when when the chart
came out i should have just brought that
out
earlier you should brought that up
earlier one thing i think is funny and
i think i hope people take away from
this is that there's people in your life
you think that that office person you're
like oh don't don't get into this with
that person they really know their stuff
just to be found even with um naomi wolf
like they don't
these people don't really know their
stuff the ambassadors don't really know
their stuff and then when you get the
people out there who uh
who are probably the most aggressive to
talk about these things you're like i
just i don't have the ammo to go up
against this person you realize when you
the circular conversations they start
happening it's because they're just
dodging and dodging and dodging and then
even when you brought out the chart it's
like shoot
well i think you had a charge i was like
oh
interesting well now the fact that
you're showing this to me you know like
fingers and toes
but you know but i'm talking about a
real woman it's just it is pushed you to
clip art yeah
see the opus oh no he's got a bristol
board
um it's the the obfuscation and listen
people out there i i hope you
you watch this and i hope it's at least
inspiring to some degree where you
realize hey
it doesn't matter who it is some people
are unconvincible is that is that a term
i think that's
some people can't i don't i might be
making google without tired i just had
to go through this twice
some people can't be convinced uh you
can still be very civil in at that point
listen her daughter's a friend her
daughter's boyfriend is a vein it's not
necessarily trying to convince this this
person but
um to showcase the truth that you know
to be self-evident to the audience and
the questioning the socratic method the
the letting the questions play out
letting them answer their own questions
it only works if it's an argument from
truth so exactly that's what's important
to me is i'm
in watching this and in conducting this
i'm i'm trying to find out if my
argument if my position is rational and
if my opponents
is rational and in in this case i
as as as bleak as it seems uh i
the the answer was pretty clear to me
hey did you enjoy this video
here's the thing you're over you're here
this is the end of it so we don't care
cause you already watched it but if you
really didn't like it
and you want to justify it leave a
comment below telling us why you didn't
like the video and if you liked us let
us know
and uh subscribe to the channel because
that lets the overlords at youtube
know that uh you know what
you're all right